[Music]
Zeno kaien aikido's forward roll the
forward roll is a major part of aikido's
ukim waza and is an essential skill in
learning to fall safely aikido's forward
roll is done shoulder to hip and not
directly over the head as is seen in
many gymnastics Styles this shoulder to
hip motion keeps the head safe by
placing the head on the opposite
shoulder you can ensure that it will
never touch the ground when initially
learning to do the forward roll simply
squat low to the ground use your arm as
a guide and throw your feet
over if this is hard for you to do it
first the mechanic can also be learned
from a sitting position while sitting in
Sea simply straighten your arm out along
the ground place your head on the
opposite shoulder and kick your feet
over doing this will give you the
confidence and mechanics necessary to
build towards the squatting roll in the
squatting roll simply squat close to the
ground use your arm as a guide and throw
your feet over the next step is the
standing R from here we do all the same
things just from
standing the next skill is develop the
jumping or dive roll as you can see the
mechanics of the jumping or dive roll
are the same as all the other rolls we
did only done more
dynamically with consistent practice you
will eventually be able to do the
forward role with no thought or
Preparation this is a major step in
enabling you to safely practice the art
of
iido this has been iido student.com
forward roll tutorial I'm Christopher
Hine thank you for
[Music]
watching